with regard to general flynn and his
unmasking
i think it goes at least up to joe biden
joe biden we now have documents that
were declassified yesterday
by rick grinnell that show that joe
biden requested the unmasking of general
flynn
[Music]
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report quick reminder everybody to
subscribe to our channel and click that
little bell so you get delivered our
videos and more importantly joining me
today is the junior senator
from kentucky and the fiercest defender
of liberty that we have in the united
states government
senator rand paul i'm thrilled you're
finally joining us i'm glad to dave glad
to be on your show
all right so let's dive in i think we're
just going to split this interview i
know you've got about a half hour we're
going to just split it into two parts
let's spend the first half talking about
this fisa amendment
uh that you just proposed can you just
talk a little bit about why you did it
what's going on with surveillance i
sense people are
seriously confused about the whole flynn
case what
the obama administration may or may not
have known so if you could just kind of
do a 101 to clean up some of that that
would be great
well the fisa court is the foreign
intelligence surveillance court and it
was set up in the 70s basically
to investigate spy on
surveill foreigners and possible
terrorists
um it was never intended really to be
used against political candidate
candidates or to
investigate american political campaigns
or american political figures
but as everybody know this is what the
the secret court that they used
to go after president trump in 2016
in the summer in the fall and uh i think
this was a horrendous abuse of power
and using a secret court to go after an
american i think is a travesty of
justice
so this is a court that lacks uh
constitutional protections
when you go to a regular court a
constitutional court that was
established by article three of the
constitution
you get a lawyer that's one obvious
thing you get but you also get the
fourth amendment the fourth amendment
says that
they can't search your house or your
phone or any of these things unless they
go to a judge
and they have to say that there's
probable cause that you committed a
crime it's a
it's a fairly high standard but it's the
constitutional standard
in the fisa court they go to it and they
say well you just have to have probable
cause that we think you
are associated with the foreign
government so that's what they do at
carter page they said oh
we see you've talked to the russians and
he said well yeah i told
the cia i'm you know i run into russians
i do business i'm in these think tanks
and i i told the cia and they know that
i've talked to the russians before and
i've tried to give them information
they discounted all that lied to device
support and then
what began this whole trump
investigation but here's my point
a lot of republicans a lot of
conservatives a lot of libertarians are
upset
how do you fix it one way of doing it is
to try to make
the fisa court system more like a
constitutional court so add protections
in the scheme of things but here's my
point i don't think it's possible to
make it constitutional
they don't notify you that they're
investigating you so it's secret
you don't get a lawyer some of the
reforms are to give you a friend
a amicus or somebody a friend of the
court that argues for you but they still
don't tell you
you've been accused of anything so you
don't really direct a lawyer to
direct your defense and so i don't think
it fixes a system so my
amendment would simply say this the fisa
court really isn't constitutional for
americans so let's exempt americans from
it
and let's use it only on foreigners it
is you know for all
it's called the foreign intelligence
court why don't we go after foreigners
with it
and people say well what if what if
there really was a spy in a political
campaign
what would you do well use the
constitution
go to a judge ask for a warrant to
search the person or to surveil the
person
and judges do grab things like that but
you have to have evidence but you'd also
have to obey the bill of rights and the
fourth amendment
that's what i'm for but unfortunately
i'm in the minority up here i think that
would win with your crowd watching
but i'm afraid probably it didn't have
enough votes in the senate to win
yeah well i assure you you're doing just
fine in the majority on my audience and
and we've got some work to do there so
can you just clarify a little bit
it seems that sort of right-leaning
twitter let's call it right now is
saying
that this stuff really went up the chain
of command then it's possible now that
biden
and or obama themselves actually knew
about it
and were we're instigating some of this
stuff what's the actual
evidence at this point well with regard
to general flynn
and his unmasking i think it goes at
least up to joe biden joe biden we now
have documents that were declassified
yesterday
by rick grinnell that show that joe
biden requested the unmasking of general
flynn what does that mean
they get like a national security or a
fisa warrant
to listen to the phone call of the
russian ambassador
i can kind of understand that we spot
ambassadors they spy on us that's what
goes on around the world
but if that ambassador is talking to a
person who's elected to our government
or part of the administration like
general flynn
they're supposed to say oh no he's
talking to an american we're not
supposed to listen
or if we listen we're not supposed to
unmask that person
well the thing is if you're a prominent
person a lot of people know you by your
voice and you may well introduce
yourself by
saying mr ambassador this is general
flynn so
it's kind of it's hard to really
completely mask it
but here's the point you're only
supposed to unmask that person if
there's a national security reason so if
they're plotting to attack the u.s
you would say well that's reasonable you
unask them to try to stop the plot
but if they're discussing policy and the
person's the national security adviser
there would be absolutely no reason
other than a politically motivated one
so if this is politically motivated then
it becomes illegal surveillance
illegal eavesdropping and really you
remember we had this
impeachment trial over them saying
someone in government
used government to go after a political
opponent turns out
what they did to general flynn sounds
exactly like that they abused government
they used surveillance to go after their
political opponent
are you worried for for a limited
government guy you don't want the
administrative state to be too big it's
like
you can get in the weeds on all of this
stuff but in many ways this is what
you've spent your whole
life fighting that peop that the whole
system has just gotten so big and crazy
at this point
that even if you tell people what's true
and we have all the facts in front of us
that sort of the ship has sailed on on
reining in the things that i think you
and i and most of my audience are
worried about
yes and no um i think if you ask your
audience obviously it's probably a very
limited government
audience but even if we ask a general
audience so for example if i ask
everybody in kentucky about whether or
not a secret court where you don't get a
lawyer should investigate political
campaigns
i wish that polls at 75 percent
particularly keep trump out of it
now trump's pretty popular in my state
so it doesn't hurt so much but really if
you could get trump out of it
but the problem is people get they won't
vote on principle and idea so i didn't
get any democrat votes on this only got
11 republicans but i got no democrats
even though many of them profess to
think that fisa has too much power and
shouldn't be investigating americans
they wouldn't vote for it
because they saw it as a vote rebuking
fisa over trump and so they saw it as a
political vote
but i guess i don't look at it this way
i lose a lot of time i'm
and i'm used to losing and votes in the
senate
but i think most of this and this is
where we do have some ability
so we pass out a sheet of uh
prominent tweets that went out from
senators each each week on wednesday and
my office does this sheet and they all
complain because
we'll put out something and my tweet
will have gotten 30 000 retweets
and then we'll put out senator so-and-so
and they got six
so right one of the things they see is
that
the liberty movement has reach well
beyond them
and they fear the electorate these
people are afraid of elections they're
afraid of me they're afraid of
conservatives
because they're afraid someday someone's
going to wake up and challenge them in
the primary
and that's what has to happen um the
democrats
it's sort of like this democrats don't
care at all about the deficit and
they'll tell you they want to spend more
money they're honest about it
republicans say they're against debt
say they're against spending but they're
also most of them
big government republicans vote lock
step with the democrats so really
when people ask me whose fault is it
republican or democrat i say
yeah you know it's really both parties
fault
but you know we could give up and just
try to protect
ourselves but you know i think if we
give up and and the few good voices here
go away
then really i think it goes much quicker
towards socialism it goes much quicker
towards
indebtedness and big government so i
have to be some voices
there needs to be more the newer people
up here i think are frankly better than
um you know the ones that have been here
a long time so i i have good
conversations with
senator braun uh senator rick scott from
florida and who i think are open to
you know under the government to both
vote me on eyes amendment mike lee with
me on the fisa amendment also
can you talk a little bit about your
relationship with trump because one of
the things that i've said to my audience
repeatedly
is first off i should tell you you'll
appreciate this i voted for gary johnson
i'm here in california
and i had the luxury of you know doing a
third party situation which obviously
certain people depending on where you
live you didn't have the luxury of doing
that
um but i wanted to make a vote for
liberty more than anything else but one
of the reasons that i've become more
okay
with trump over the last couple of years
is that the guy that i respect
most in the senate you has become one of
his big allies and my feeling was well
if rand paul
who i align with on so much of the
liberty stuff sees something in him
that he can work with then i view that
as a net good
can you talk about a little bit about
your relationship personally but also
just
what do you think his actual governing
principles are because it's hard to say
they're traditionally conservative or
republican or
whatever else he doesn't come from a
steeped
uh developed notion or philosophy
of libertarianism however when you talk
to him about
war and he talks about the iraq war he
gets it more than any other republican
obviously other than my dad or myself
or mike lee he gets it if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell